fait rentrer des photos yacine tu vas me
dire ce que tu penses de ces gens
d'accord regarde alors attention c'est
parti
les premières photos on va démarrer fort
puisque on va démarrer par ils sont
crashées ou sont en train de taper sur
google je te dis tout ça et eric zemmour
qui va s'appeler et régler mots ils sont
en train de se trouver à normalement
voilà la n'ose même pas venir ben voilà
eric zemmour du beau tu pourrais nous
dire quoi eric zemmour patriote c'est
pas sa meilleure photo la fnac
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la toile datant de ses news
ouais patriote on est en désaccord sur
tout ça n'empêche pas qu'on peut on peut
discuter
après le débat que j'ai fait avec lui ce
qui est assez drôle c'est que on a
tendance à l'oublier mais c'est ni lui
ni moi qui avons gagné jour là c'est
surtout ses news
et en général fait 0,6 pour cent
d'audience et journalise et 1 6%
donc pascal praud était ravi de dire ce
qu'il a dit sur ta soeur c'est parti
dans tous les sens quoi mais en tout cas
eric zemmour ouais je pense que il ya un
conflit générationnel culturel pas
cultuelle parce qu'il a le droit d'être
autre chose que musulman mais en tout
cas j'ai lié ma vie à une partie de la
sienne peut être david pujadas parce que
tu as vu un échange musclé sur le
plateau de 24 heures peut jada sur lci
ouais ils allaient revenant sur cette
photo est gentil d'avis le dirigeant
comme mot à mot pour lui un mot pour
chacun
parfois sans mauvais jeu de mots
mauvaise foi j'en veux tu vois moi je là
où j'étais en désaccord avec lui c'est
sur le bar de sevran c'est lui qui avait
fait le reportage qui avait incriminé se
barre en disant que c'était un repaire
de djihadistes il s'avère que j'ai mis
un petit peu de sous dans ce bar l'âge
les invités à venir et faire un beau
sujet pour sortir par le haut il n'a
jamais voulu venir il a voulu camper sur
ses positions et tuer lui donner un nom
d'animaux parce que je l'avais appelé
j'en ai fait un perroquet ou pourquoi ce
qu'il répète beaucoup ce qu'il entend
d'accord marine le pen serait quoi comme
un animal ouais ben autant son père on
savait que c'était un requin blanc elle
ce sera justement ce je crois que
l'animal le plus le poisson le plus
dangereux de l'océan n'est pas ce n'est
pas n'est pas leur cas j'ai oublié son
nom
c'est un mac est ce qui me parlent à
gaza
jean michel berrit dans ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que tous autant que
nous sommes dans cette société politico
médiatique
nous pouvons peut-être voir cette femme
arrivée au pouvoir vraiment moi je pense
que je m'en remettrai pas je serai là
pour combattre mais cette banalisation
qui a réussi à noah a réussi à nous
persuader cette femme est quand même un
truc alors qu'il avait déclaré sur elle
dans son programme pour les
présidentielles même l'écologie c'était
de la faute des musulmans prochaine et
prochaine prochain visage c'est yann
barthès et avait déclaré au sujet de
barthez il n'est même pas capable
d'aller en seine-saint-denis avec c'est
stan smith blanche malades l'édile ça
c'est clair
ouais ouais ben je pense que cette
espèce de truc un peu on y va on y va
pas au moins ici je suis dans une
émission qui assume ses positions à
travers ses chroniqueurs à travers son
animateur ce qui est bien yann barthès
et qu'il n'est pas capable d'assumer
certaines positions la banlieue c'est
pas chic
soit on prend la banlieue dans son
intégralité on prend tous les problèmes
qu'il ya dedans mais on prend pas une
espèce d'élite de la banlieue
des mecs un peu chic aux cd qu'ils ont
des problèmes on dit ah mais c'est pas
nous qui les avons choisis non moi je
suis pas d'accord avec le ton de
l'émission
et puis surtout la pampa relents
politiques aux politiques
yann barthès il a surtout fait quelque
chose c'est qu'il a un fort utilisé la
politique française
aujourd'hui les jeunes savent pas ce que
c'est un homme politique de gauche ou de
droite ils se disent je veux pas pour ce
mec là parce qu'il a mis trois fois la
même cravate
ça a été ça pendant longtemps un petit
peu le petit journal et connaît donc
aujourd'hui moi je trouve qu'il a il a
pu faire du bon boulot mais là il faut
commencer à se poser les bonnes
questions
emmanuel macron puisque td le conseiller
de mon lieu de emmanuel macron si
c'était un animal bas le caméléon je
pense en ce que je sais toujours pas si
les droits tout golf fin il est au
milieu
ouais ouais non non non après ça c'est
un homme brillant faut dire la vérité
la réalité c'est que il est au
croisement des chemins entre une france
en colère et et son mandat
les gilet jaune ça serait arrivé même si
on avait acheté pour iron man
le truc c'est que sur les sur la
banlieue sur le quelque chose surtout
moi qui me touche qui est celui du vivre
ensemble
c'est un président qui n'arrive pas à
comprendre cette idée de la france soit
autant fracturée